a new program and we don't know how well
this is going we need to make sure this
is how it should introduce all of our
live streams mm-hmm can you hear us are
we allowed to swear are we are we all
the record are we coming across good
right now's like every podcast are we
overdoing it yeah are we doing it this
we're using a fancy new streamer so we
got you know yeah we just wanted to show
off like we can put graphics now oh and
uh thanks to the peeps at stream yard
yeah they're a wonderful service don't
worry they're not sponsoring never in
response we're here just because we
don't make money courtesy of stream yard
but yay huzzah
so can you guys hear us all right don't
worth a comma can you hear me now good
week oh they can hear us
Mikhail's in the chat all right guys so
let's uh let's see here oh you got
awesome so nothing's lagging right
because we're running a lot of
experiments were really worried that it
wasn't gonna work yeah no don't swear
please that's what they said Oh Matt
beer what Matt beer thank you so much
Matt here buddy flashing your super chat
on screen that's his face I hope your
ears been good so far - it's been pretty
good John and I met up to meet on we met
up to meet on New Year's Day after very
little estate to film acquired plays -
and we're both kind of noxious ly sick
like really quick after like a flu but
on the scale of a cold yeah it's weird
if you got what I got I don't know I was
pretty sick we made out sick that day
ended up i catched up on some hobbies
though I like to write and all those
things but guys really quick what did
you think of the Golden Globes
what did you think oh we gotta make sure
this video is not child friendly [ __ ]
god damn it what all right good damn
Papa a horror of hell yeah yeah so what
did you guys think of the Golden Globes
nothing no no one cares about the Golden
I'll say what I think Richy Gervase is
freaking hilarious man hi I have I was
so out of the loop about the Golden
Globes that I didn't even
I know he was gonna be on that night
until like 30 minutes before it was on
and B I didn't know Ricky Gervais yeah I
didn't know and I found out like the day
before oh is that tomorrow yeah I mean I
don't think it'll be I I could see him
being the one to say that is his last
one like him making that declaration but
I think the Golden Globes have want him
to come back because clearly people he
keeps being brought back the more
offensive he gets the more they talk
about it and the more people love it
yeah and it's clear that like that's the
thing that works for them it seems like
and it's funny because I saw some people
on social media being like ah get him
off the stage he's just disgrace to this
and I'm like they they hired ya the
Foreign Press hired this guy and yeah he
just said what he it didn't even feel
like he wrote jokes just said what he
felt if you guys ever feel like the lag
that the the livestream is just not
working for you please start commenting
so we can just make sure because like I
said we're experimenting with a new
program alright keep us abreast of the
quality my favorite part of the Golden
Globes personally was Tarantino speech I
did but I did it on my own ego on the
guy that's so Terry but it's yeah this
is a weird thing about Tarantino's like
you you sort of expected from Tarantino
yeah
very shocking it here even the crowd was
like Jesus Christ there's plenty of
people who've won being the sole writer
huh he's like like I don't want to thank
you know it's not the inspiration of all
these films or anybody who I may have
like consulted for this look how great I
am like Tarantino speech if there's one
thing we can all agree on Carter
Lovejoy's the Jeffrey Epstein in kill
himself
yeah so one thing but yeah that
Tarantino's I love when they cut around
to cuz like the Oscars seem more
dignified in the golden glow
seem like very off-the-cuff yeah and so
you're cutting around to people even
them being like oh my goodness John the
show up some of our graphics here let's
let's let's put our let's put our logos
on screen look we figured out and we're
so late in the game but we figured out
how to like throw oh my god look that's
where you can follow Wow all our social
networks for the real regions as well no
obviously in the courtesy of jte for
introducing the program you can even
hide these and just show our little
company name here and if you want a
minimal look at that is all we wanted to
do mostly unab we just wanted to show
you guys that we'll have better looking
live streams look now they're gonna be
pink and now we're going back to Orange
wrong orange though let's stop showing
off let's stuff showing up with these
compari let's leave an scrap every
graphic we gotta go back to the oh no
someone really doesn't like Tarantino in
here I'm sorry to hear that
well John John Johnson 1917 twice
already I have a MCA list and I didn't
um I'm waiting for a 1917 to come on AMC
because why would I pay for it I want
her to pay monthly for it yeah so I want
to go on imax to catch it's going on
IMAX right looks like it looks like an
IMAX movie so I would love to go watch
on I'm the largest most immersive format
possible go go see that movie Tom Hanks
was crunching a whole monologue by
Gervais is so shrew he looks very
uncomfortable oh yeah oh yeah well
especially after like that Apple remark
basically saying like you know you can't
stand on a moral high ground when the
companies you're working for which which
is a good point and it's a tough point
because Amazon 2 has pretty bad worker
uh you know cue me pretty bad conditions
for their SWA warehouse workers and
stuff and Apple obviously yeah sweatshop
labor thanks oh yeah it was like every
celebrity was gonna get up and give like
a political speech that night probably
had to feel bit self-aware after that
well
Britney we did why I watched the first
episode of The Witcher well how how we
live stream is
we talk free to comment hey I watch one
episode of The Witcher I need to watch
the rest toss him a coin I did I don't
know exactly we talk about but hell yeah
the only reference I understand is
everyone just toss a coin dear Witcher
thanks to more happy to be back Justin
appreciate that buddy oh dude
when Joaquin Phoenix said he loved
Rooney Mara was he drunk he seemed I've
seen walking Phoenix behave weird plenty
of times but I was like it's he's got to
be drunk and I'm really happy he won -
yeah he seemed he seemed like he either
felt drunk or awkward or both I couldn't
tell if they're like dating or something
now or if the yeah that was just a
random call out somebody who's on the
celeb gossip are you surprised have you
seen the Irishman yet yes oh you didn't
did you like it yeah can I get Jonah
winery forever over the weekend okay
love it I liked it a lot I I am still
processing it you know when I watched
people who weren't keen on it so I was
most keen oh jeez
but ya know I appreciate it quite a bit
I really liked it a lot if people are
talking a lot about parasite I'm gonna
watch it tonight first time I'm excited
I'm excited for you oh god Matt beer
thank you buddy for the super chat if I
started a streaming service its Collier
it's such that I was like cooking
watching this on my phone
they're engaged who's engaged they're
engaged
choosing aged they're engaged who's
engaged Joaquin Phoenix and oh no that's
the wrong one anyway Olivia yeah
Joaquin Phoenix and Rooney Mara are
engaged yeah and they meet on the set of
her but that's where they met oh there
you go that makes perfect yes I
personally think uh well you know what
some people will definitely disagree
with me
Irishman one of my top like three or
four favorite movies of the year I can
actually see why Brad Pitt one for Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood you know it now
I think Joe Pesci doesn't
I would never push I said I was like
wait a minute now this Brad Pitt was
being Rapids great unless upon a time in
Hollywood and he and he steals the show
whenever he's on screen but he's perhaps
hid in that movie you know essentially
yeah I wonder if it was a canceled out
situation where maybe because like
Pacino has gotten a lot of attention for
that movie true or so I wonder if maybe
Pesci and Pacino both cancelled each
other out
yes and also like everybody loves cliff
boots you know yeah I think the
character was more loved and I don't
know the Joe Pesci screen I would have
given it to Joe Pesci's incredible in
that movie I mean like some haven't read
one but I think yeah and especially all
of his speech do yeah yeah
but yeah Joe Pesci and he was like the
one I was most excited to see come back
in and play against you know because
that movie has a sort of life that
references casino and Goodfellas just by
what it is in general I thought it was
cool to see Joe Pesci play a different
type of character in this realm right so
similar but different
Vincent we love you we love you Vincent
so much Newman and Carter Lovejoy as
well yeah I love it I know that Ricky
Gervais is brother you know Martin
Scorsese I know that the generic the
general thing is just to go over all the
awards and talk about the snubs and
whatever was the Peter Nyong'o nominated
not that I recall
Jesus and everyone just forget about
Lupita speaking of Collider movie talk I
don't remember who was honest - people
have been bringing up Collider there was
there was someone on Collider movie talk
a few weeks ago who said sometimes I
would listen to a show for just my
earphones on you know like mom cooking
or cleaning and someone said the female
performances have just not been as
strong as the male performances this
year like some guy said that and I hope
literally were just like Lupita Nyong'o
do what are you crazy
best performances of the year that's two
movies worth of acting and yeah it's
it's a crime she wasn't so many got yeah
that movie got no love it
I don't know maybe because people did
not want to sue somebody I don't know
what it is and actually I saw us again
you know not long ago and and I really
appreciated it that much more than a
second yeah I think the lighthouse
people have been bringing it up I think
the lighthouse might have some good odds
in the technical department for the
Oscars yeah I I can see why got tell me
wrong like willing to phone pad it have
you seen it yet no loser actually John's
probably see more moves than me this
year yeah the lighthouse the
performances that are incredible but I
think it's the technical achievements
that stand out more so I feel like come
Oscar season that's the thing that's
really gonna stand out I feel like
that's the main complaint I've heard
from a lot of people about the
lighthouse is that the emotional
engagement factor isn't so much there
but the technicals are dazzling yes
absolutely the and you know the Oscars
inevitably will pick up some things that
the Golden Globes don't touch it all
mm-hmm so that's true Sandler I think
I've seen it before
where an actor is not nominated at all
during the Golden Globes but then they
get an Oscar nomination especially when
there's such an outpour of like why was
he nominated I haven't seen uncut gems
yet there's I have a whole list of
movies I need to catch up I haven't seen
Josie there's a reason why John I do not
do a top ten because I'm like there's so
many movies yeah that's also like what
we did see is you know kind of a narrow
margin compared to like the breadth of
things were talking about so there's
probably gonna be a lot of redundancy if
we were to do that you know with other
people's lists because I saw I only saw
Jojo rabbit
hello everyone everyone who do here I
only saw Jojo rabbit us is my favorite
horror movie of the year by the way just
last week and I was like whoa this is
like probably my top five knives outta
there like there's a lot of everybody's
we've caught up on that we haven't did
it have the chance to review just
because we caught them late but knives
out I think is incredible no nominations
obviously no Daniel Craig Dan afraid oh
yeah that's - or what do you think about
Aaron Henderson winning I've seen people
in this chat be like no don't like Taran
hydrogen winning for that you know I to
me when I was handicapping it I thought
it would be down
either him or Eddie Murphy and I loved
rocket man's so I'm really happy for
Terron Edgerton if it wasn't him I would
have liked to have seen a good idea
Murphy though I think Eddie Murphy
deserved it as as well as he did he did
it in Korea I watched all of mine is my
name and I like the movie I loved his
perform yeah it was like a difference
he's in there I'm like hey performance I
love I really like the movie but I don't
love it but I loved his performance a
hell of actually I I started like
looking at the trailers for the movie
they were making in Dolomites as many
yeah I loved that was awesome but I
thought turned in an excellent job the
categories of musical or comedy and
usually goes to like a comedy so yeah I
think to give it to a musical yeah you
know a comedy like once upon a time in
Holland and I thought I didn t know for
a Golden Globe yeah comedy the Golden
Gloves don't really acknowledge what is
it actual comedy you know which which
mostly drama but not quite weren't we
able to fit into the drama category just
put that on in comedy and let it win
it's weird
I like I like I love the show of the
Golden Globes significantly more than I
love watching the Oscars yet I know the
Oscars the the the award of it means a
lot more than the Golden Gloves but I
think the Golden Globe show is
significantly more entertaining
generally speaking the rules [ __ ]
drunk yeah yeah
I couldn't tell was happening with Renee
Zellweger I was like is she I couldn't
tell if she was like almost cuz you know
she's had a long time out of the
spotlight and then the way she was
giving her speech was almost like beat
poetry I couldn't tell if she was
feeling anxious or drunk or both yeah
that's true
no that's true Tom Hanks this speech is
really nice yeah very emotional stuff
Miriam it's it's a pure Tom Hanks speech
yes the only way to really describe it
you're you you must be this guy the two
honorary Awards I thought were great
speeches because Ellen's speech was
hilarious
yeah and heartfelt but like that whole
thing like thanking my husband Mike you
know and just like all these
facts did you take what hey everyone
everyone uh uh did you take the the bit
about what Joaquin Phoenix said at the
end of his speech about you know like
not taking trips to Palm Springs with
Shawn didn't private yeah did you take
that as a dig any of the people in the
crowd I would imagine because actually
the funny thing is the day we went to
Palm Springs the day the festival
started and so they were doing all these
we were eating dinner and they were had
the interviews the red carpet on TV so I
imagine that he's probably just saying a
lot of the celebrities you have probably
flew in on private jets when they didn't
have to yeah that sucks up tons and tons
of gas and you know pollutes a lot so I
haven't seen the farewell but I thought
it was great that an Asian actress won
and I loved her speech - yeah sometimes
a speech isn't really it's like it's not
the wind that makes me watch sometimes
it's the speech that makes me go I'm
gonna watch that movie yeah and 40
percent of the time I do maybe 40 60
percent of the time it works every time
at the irishman um on the table with
Scorsese mm-hmm I couldn't tell they're
just really old and tired or or if
they're actually like he seemed like a
little annoyed and upset Scorsese
that he didn't win I just everything
they cut to him he just seemed like he
wasn't having a good time
there were a couple moments where people
got him to chuckle but yeah I wonder if
he's just so used to this he's just kind
of chilling and hating around
speaking of like the Scorsese comments
that have been circulating like the past
six moments for something he said he
doesn't he doesn't want to watch he
doesn't care to watch The Joker because
he's already deal I know what happens in
it blah blah blah and he's seen clips or
whatever I'm like you're a homeboys and
De Niro's in it yeah yeah Ted it - well
one of your most iconic movies and one
of your most underrated movies yeah I
read it for Todd Phillips that's a major
bummer to hear that yeah I do have to
I'm yeah pretty sad mazdan Scorsese like
helped produce that I talked see where
it
the a say epic CBO says it sources a no
expression was must stack reviews thanks
so much buddy
oh love tossed rallying John do your
voice hi guys as a Gowen big fan from
Australia was wondering if you've seen
midsummer or the nightingale
two of my favorites from the year no but
I rewatched hereditary while I was sick
I say you saw midsummer I saw the
midsummer director's cut and I really
really enjoyed that it's it's weird I I
don't know if it's a better movie than
hereditary but it's more enjoyable yeah
like it's it's just as like pitch-black
cringy but also like really funny in a
sick way so uh how I watch it yeah I
hear it's very much inspired that feels
like wick man totally yeah and I really
want to see the nightingale it's a
Jennifer Kent's follow-up to the
babadook damn Luis Sanchez is a hey Tina
aquafina here what get out
oh gosh the movie I Jorge it's all right
buddy it's all right John pick a random
question here alright it's John from
Australia Nomad mirror I am not
seriously Australia is burning up send
them love and support and money please
play what won Best Picture nineteen
seventeen nineteen which I mean well one
one musical or comedy
oh did it yeah Wow the comedy once upon
a time Tarantino's that rare person here
like keep it's cuz he doesn't like let
me know that some [ __ ] that came out a
couple years ago he's not known to be an
abusive guy you know yeah so because of
that you can get away with ego yeah he's
yeah I feel like Tarantino teeters ever
on the edge of morality and even though
there are people even in this chat who
don't like Tarantino generally rob lowes
are all really lovely thanks Arthur PA
you're on I love your dog don't let
Brooke youtubers spit on your dog love
your comments all right it's the first
time I brought that youtuber up
oh yeah as we're going through his
favorite flicks of the year what sir
what's our favorite flick of the year
hmm that's a hard poem but I'm gonna
watch parasite tonight genre saw
parasite great yeah and parasite was was
a cool experience the first like truly
foreign film I had seen in a little
while in a theater and I was like
writhing and giggling at the same time
for like most of the movie it's really
well crafted I don't really have a full
list like if I were to just spit them
out at the top of my head I've just
random movies that I loved this year I
mean everyone knows and game for sure
hmm you got to sit end game you guys
thank you
you gots a joker you gotta say Joker I'm
gonna lay down take here Carter Lovejoy
let's know how many Razzies cats will be
none all of them and we'll win all of
them but you know what else cashier
nominated for cats is nominated for my
tenth favorite film of these John okay
while we're talking about their movies
John not messing with the game in the
came over here at the day after he saw
cats and I don't know asked like what he
did he's like I saw cats I'm like oh
he's like actually I really like I know
like did you like it cuz it's like so
bad he's like no I think I think I just
got with a rig don't get me wrong it is
something to get used to because the
animation is is surreal and drugged
trippy and my opinion will not make
anybody like this movie I know I'm alone
yeah but understanding what cats is and
is supposed to be and then having seen
this movie I went in being told you'll
enjoy this the way you enjoyed the room
and I was like great I'm psyched for
that experience and then halfway through
I was like just having a good time
what's up with this really appreciate it
cuz like yeah it's wall-to-wall music
and so like it created this
hallucinatory state for me where I was
like this is one of the most fascinating
strange and engaging movies I've seen in
a while and I have no idea how or why it
got made and I'm glad it did because of
all the things I've seen it's arguably
one of the most distinct all years so
for that reason alone
Thanks our shoe I love you I'm glad that
somebody else feels me on this
so now although my credibility is
destroyed I'm not trying to be a typical
contrarian I went in her for a terrible
time and then I was like you know what
the way they shot this it's not bad the
the scant the one thing I can absolutely
complain about those the scaling of the
cats is every which way everyone talking
about cats get a chance to shine here on
the camera well and the other thing too
is I think cats is really really easy to
hate automatically because most people I
mean the musical was very successful but
people hate the musical because musical
doesn't make sense it is just a bunch of
cats introducing themselves so like as a
direct translation of what the musical
is I had fun yeah it's not a great film
but I had a great time yeah sue me oh
I'll die on this hill I'm not in a rush
so watch don't worry they aren't sending
out screeners and you'll never be able
to see it anywhere once they are
stricken it from the record Hey Hey look
thank you so much
look read his question in your super
chatting I love the impersonation come
and visit I run a farm stay accomodation
site you're welcome anytime for free
remember my user and hit me I'm gonna
screenshot you because I would love to
go to Australia someday anywho so what
have we got out of the way uh although
cats Irishmen absolutely oceans great
yeah
honestly yeah I thought for sure endgame
would be my number one and I feel like
it still is but Jojo rabbits really high
up there Jojo rabbits very high up um as
I have what and I don't know it's the
most recent one I've seen yeah so that
could be that effect - I was falling in
love with a movie that you just recently
seen but I was so impressed with totally
how how well he rode that line of
knowing when it could be offensive or
disrespectful but knowing when you be
like hilarious they're like the whole
like Iowa
at the very beginning was just like some
freaking funny oh and I all right like
ireally towards the end of that I really
cried like twice when I watched that
movie I was I was touched yeah
as I adored that film a lot yeah and
then also knives out I would say is
definitely my top five weirdly I I'm a
Tarrant I'm a I'm a huge Tarantino fan
I'm not sure what's about time
hollywood's in my ultimate top ten I'm
not sure either I really really
appreciate it and it's definitely a
standout of the year it's kind of like a
Ford V Ferrari where I was like I
thought this is great I really liked it
the the film is terrific it's definitely
a highlight of the year I don't know if
it's one of my absolute favorites of the
year but definitely worth seeing worth
mentioning all that you know it's always
the men yeah did not see missing Lincoln
I'm really bummed about that but I'm
really happy for them because that movie
didn't perform very well and now maybe
it'll get some more attention because
you know stop-motion should not die and
neither should 2d animation so go watch
Klaus - wow this whole thing has become
about cats John that's what you've done
we have it as title talking about the
golden club I would die of cats play my
position any time nobody else has to
like I saw the first season of the I've
seen the first season of The Office UK
version but I I think I did myself a
disservice by watching the American
version like so many of the seasons of
the American version first mmm because
it's so much meaner that I didn't
appreciate it but whenever I watch clips
so I think I think that Gervaise
versions way more uncomfortable and a
little meaner yeah I mean the first
season of the American office borders on
that especially like Michael Scott is a
lot less redeemable yeah but yeah the
British office is much more scathing I
think it's so honestly Wheaton my weird
pick endgame or go Jo rabbit is probably
is my favorite movie it's one of those
two knives out definitely one of my
favorites as well and us I adored the
hell out of that film and I feel like
there's there's gonna be more right
not Halle was in the her she started
writing was I hoped I wouldn't forget
but you know what right now I think my
favorite film and again I'm being ginger
about this because I've just seen it
recently but 1917 I thought was really
fantastic to see that it's it's really
got to see that once I won't say too
much about it but what's great about
1917 is that every technical thing
you've heard about being impressive is
absolutely impressive and somehow you
forget about all those things while
you're watching it so like the whole
one-take thing never feels like a
gimmick and everything coalesce is to
support the physical story yes and it's
it's a really beautifully vulnerably
done film and I can't say enough about
it really it is still way for that uh
spoiler get on that McHale have not yet
seen which I'm gonna call it what do you
just asked I'm sorry Charlie we're still
not pros like keeping up with these
chernobyl oh you gotta watch that we got
a we got a weird schedule it's like we
do all the filming and editing blah blah
blah and then on patreon we cover all
these shows so then when I and there's
some shows I watched just for myself
like crisis on Infinite Earths which by
the way is coming back soon I'm sure my
opinions about that yet but I guess the
crisis itself is coming back right yeah
the crisis is coming back it's called
real life it's called the start of
January 2020 about everything's been
going there yeah yeah so uh but like
then their shows were I like I just
really want to why I don't want to miss
an episode with my girlfriend on it like
which is one of those shows Watchmen
watchman's my favorite show of last year
I mean I would really love Mandalorian I
do but Watchmen has got to be my
favorite show of last year for sure and
yeah that's why probably say that a
beautiful day in the neighborhood was
definitely one that touched me in my
soul jelly especially because you know
having mr. Rogers growing up and all
that but it really does a beautiful job
of like translating both the style of
his show and his spirit and Tom Hanks's
a treasure so and and I did you ever see
the documentary no I'm doing this in
they could watch the doctor this
documentary sucks those are cover half
the things I saw in that movie your what
about not not that it's necessarily
gonna top any of our lists but John wick
3 I think is definitely like a standout
for action this year we're like you guys
I don't know who saw a review for John
wick 3 but when we watched on week 3 sin
Mason I don't think elite is the best
movie of the year but love for a leader
love for alia so okay so yeah there was
a John wick through who is playing in
the background we're hanging out Andrew
Gordon's place and every time there was
action John are playing pool but every
time there's actually we just like
stoppages watch that and it's like most
of the movie is too good for sure
Lana Pico hey Lana from Hawaii your reel
is the real one
being part Asian I want to shout out
aquafina for winning Best Actress music
on furfrou well yeah you probably were
here at the era at the early part of it
but that's exactly what I'm crafting
actress to win once you're out sir are
you full Asian hmmm half asian I'm half
Filipino so for me I'm like yeah agents
are making a stamp man crazy rich Asians
that's it
we got three Asian movie movies whereas
I won hell yeah that's what I'm talking
about oh he made a great remark about
once you can get past the one-inch
barrier of subtitles the world of cinema
will open up to you or something like
that
did you already Thank You Vanessa Smith
Negi lana by the way did you already
talk about Ricky Gervais of saying
exactly what we all want - I'm late here
love your channel Croton
let's not explain to people no I mean
let's just have you're on your own
people Nessa shouting out her Croats yes
we did talk some about Ricky but if
there's a specific joke you want to
reminisce about BTS their first music
video we reacted to on YouTube there is
a wide and CRO kid it's gonna give a
different meaning yeah
like wrote it but yeah we did that was
what do you mean exactly what we all
want to like in his monologue or just
throughout the night ribbing on me no I
thought it was great especially like he
knew Ricky Gervais to read a crowd
incredibly well he'll he'll know how a
crab man wouldn't want to care about
what I think when he made the the Harvey
Weinstein jab and the crowd was like oh
he's like that's on you yeah like he
knew exactly how they worked for him
yeah that's that was brilliant on him
and then but yeah the whole thing about
not saying political stuff and then
taking jabs at how most of them really
are not as actively involved as they try
to make themselves seem like well yeah
kind of like the place on the whole
thing that I hate with the word
influencer of most influencers are not
really influenced if I try to inspire
they're just like people call us
influencers I'm like we're not trying to
teach you guys were like sharing change
your life or something we're talking
about movies primarily gosh hey guys go
watch our new mutants trailer reactions
it's demonetized
yes we'd like you to still watch it
anyway why not support it the Irish cat
who we got to see that match up it's
very chic at yeah all right guys we're
gonna log off here in a couple minutes
we just wanted to test this out but now
that we got this working we're gonna be
doing more live streams we've really
been liking it but let's get a let's get
a speed round a quick answers going in
here going 20 20 birds of prey when's
the new trailer coming out for that it's
like one real trailer and it comes out
next month well snap what where the hell
is the next [ __ ] trailer for that
movie is there anything this month that
could get packaged with I don't I don't
understand what's double you don't have
anything coming out makes no sense Luke
Sanchez has some I haven't seen marriage
story
I keep senior curity minutes of marriage
I keep joking with my girlfriend about
let's go sit down and watch bears I'm
not sure I want to do that hmm Matt beef
thanks Matt beer classic Mac your
question go to Casa Vega where you can
get the parents to know margarita go to
Musso and Frank's a
and Marc veggie grill macelli's Italian
restaurant a spice off of Highland
Avenue is a great restaurant go Feist
yeah spice go find the original in and
out wherever that is they say there's a
problem with the mic is this true this
is true mics on oh no no Mike's son hold
on buddy open up the settings have we
lost everyone audio it's reading on our
end line
I think birds of prey will still do well
hmm you know I still think it'll do well
oh but yeah there's still hide they
already have a complete line of Funko
pops I saw over the weekend guys when we
say it's free to download and follow us
in the Stardust app that's the best
place to get her a quick opinion I think
and then you know we also want to use
these live streams to generally catch up
for videos that you know we don't we
might not shoot to edit yeah if we
didn't react to something or if there's
like a movie that we didn't review
formally but yeah here we'll give a
couple there's a lot of reviews for
movies that we totally miss out on but
like when we do our reviews it takes a
while to set up with the mic system we
have might not look like a lot of when
you see the full video but those with
the syncing and the editing those
usually take about like a two to three
hour assembly and then they do all right
you can't lending depending on whatever
it's like Star Wars or Avengers but so
yeah we want to use this to like
actually like have this open forums of
these questions that way we can you know
share our opinions on things like how I
just broke down my experience with Joe
Joe rabbit so that's why we were pretty
adamant about getting this live stream
format working with you guys
I started Clone Wars by the way episode
4 I here I'm watching it not in
chronological order because of the way
it's been released which is kind of
weird I don't know why they would do
that but hey what they're set photos of
Robert Pattinson the Batman movie Jon
pull them up and show them the feature
that we can deal with showing the photo
all right on here here we go we're gonna
start a shared screen so when we get the
photo first no we're gonna show them us
googling it oh my god which this is the
new tab here we go and then we're gonna
pop that in here I'll looky there
that man mo he's like some weird thing
shows up in the auto we don't look wait
a minute okay the first look oh damn
that's not him oh it's a mustache that
it's him but oh my god own photo oh it's
nothing wheats it's it's Gotham Action
News Oh
it has the word Gaza oh there's Quitman
is there a crazy bear colleagues that
call feral and penguin maybe his hair is
gray that's that penguin he's got guys
around penguin he's got an umbrella
that's the last picture from this wait
wait who's this that guy's scratching
his crotch he's scratching his crotch
it's definitely scratching his girl oh
my god they're actually filming I didn't
know they were actually filming it yeah
filming people scratching their clothes
no actually filming it I didn't know
they were they started filming it so now
I thought they were still like oh I have
to switch the page we're still learning
how this stuff works
but yeah let's see let's oh I know what
to do let's just blow these oh yeah
there we go
oh yeah we're doing this guy's yes we
got this crotch scratch and motorcycle
guy yeah we won't stop showing off all
right all right
ooh look GCPD who's this is that the
Peng oh man in addition wow these are
super exciting foods I'm not seeing the
one for that one
but hey Obi one Ben Kenobi's but a lot
of people are talking about here - I've
been watching even Washington since
you're 11 Deborah nah they're too young
to be watching that's we can't advertise
to you hey hey I love this comment thank
you so much oh all right guys well thank
you so much for being here
no lunch crawl I'm glad that this live
stream worked Thank You jte for okay fur
okay I'll put it do telling that's a
program that seemed to work for you
shouts out to Roman Griffin Davis I
think he could have been a good best
actor - and we'll catch you guys soon
John flash our logo oh look out
sup brand logos now and the live stream
much love thank you everyone was super
chatted peace